for the second time in the last few
weeks we're hearing about someone flying
a
jet pack in the sky near one of our
busiest airports a boeing 777
reported an unidentified flying object
soaring above
los angeles yesterday afternoon
we just saw the flight object like a
flight still kept tanking by
6000. a flying object was it a
uav or was it a jet pack
a lag chris van cleave joins us chris
what do we know about this latest
incident
well good morning the high altitude
mystery continues the faa says a china
airlines crew from taiwan reported what
appeared to be a jet pack flying around
six thousand feet
about seven miles from lax yesterday
other planes in the area did not spot
the unknown object but
the faa and fbi are investigating
similar sightings near lax in late
august
there two pilots on separate flights saw
what they described as a person wearing
a jet pack flying near their airliners
it's not clear what was actually seen or
if there's any link between these
incidents
jet packs are actually a real thing but
only a few companies make them
after the first reports the ceo of
jetpack aviation in la told us it would
be nearly impossible for someone to fly
a jet pack thousands of feet up
and get back down safely they're also
not commercially available very
expensive and very noisy so
it's unlikely somebody could take off
and land in densely populated los
angeles and no one would see it
and of course iron man zipping around la
would certainly light up social media
gail chris thank you very much